[Music]
Rupert how you doing man so uh this
amazing show It's the final season if
you look back at this gray interesting
character and Julian that you play what
would you say is the most redeemable
quality of his character
I have a question because I mean
originally I found him a very unlikable
human being he kind of represents
everything that he's kind of wrong with
Society he's just really Brash kind of
privileged guy who loves to kind of
flash his his wealth and um and he's got
some very kind of
bad views and he drinks and he and he
just over overuses all of these things
he's very kind of hedonistic and he's
very fun to play I love I love that side
of him but as the show's kind of
developed he's we see him grappling with
kind of more deeper things the guilt
which links him to the tragedy of the
show and um yeah it's interesting to see
someone kind of crumble yeah well thank
you for bringing us this great character
performance I'm excited for people to
see this final season thanks Rupert